As you know, the human body has countless enemies: viruses, bacteria of various sorts,
which can cause either major illnesses or less serious ones, such as the common cold.
To fight the germs, the body has a police force of white corpuscles, which you as cadet
lymphocytes are being trained to become.
There are also the specialists, polymorphs, and of course the microphages, the antibodies,
and many, many others.
The body is also attacked by a great number of poisons.
Toxins, gases, chemical products, some of which are natural, but others, the majority, are man-made.
To protect the body against these toxins, every cell has special agents called detoxifying enzymes,
which are produced specifically for this purpose.
We must hurry up, you know, or we'll be late for lunch again.
Just look at all that awful pollution.
With all those exhaust fumes, it's a wonder we can even breathe.
Ha ha!
Ah shit!
We've got an invasion.
Here on the tonsil battlefield, we are in the front line of defense.
Look who are trying to sneak their way in.
Our bacterial friend.
Bacteria aren't the easiest things to digest.
Watch out, there's some more nasty filth creeping in-
Don't get so worried, Chief. They're not germs.
They're only pollution and smoke particles or something.
But they're unhealthy.
Well, the enzymes can take care of them in there.
They're used to dealing with that type of-
Much further now, Professor Globus.
Give me your hand, I'll help you.
We've nearly reached the alveoli of the lung and then we'll be able to breathe some lovely pure air.
Throw polluted bubbles!
What kind of contraption is that?
I'm afraid there's still some pollution down there, Captain.
Calling all macrophage units.
We've spotted some toxic particles, zones 35 of the lung arterioles.
Eliminate at once!
They've gone, Captain, but we'll have to send the macrophages and other white corpuscles after them.
They'll have difficulty in finding them.
They're chemical pollutants and very dangerous.
I don't like the look of them.
Checked you.
I wouldn't have done that.
I would have moved the bishop.
Jake again!
Let's see, I think I will move my bishop.
Hey, what's that?
Do you see what's approaching there?
It's pollution, don't worry about it.
It's outside the cell.
I'm sure that the others will see to it that it's destroyed.
It's your turn.
They look like cell pollutants to me.
They might try to break in, don't you think?
Oh, no, I assure you, we're quite safe here.
But some pollutants can penetrate the membrane.
Uh, I think I'll play this one here, yeah.
You only did that because you're losing!
The humans are here!
They've broken the cell wall!
Sound the alarm!
Ah!
What are the enemy?
They're at the cell wall.
They've entered.
They're out of our reach!
What are they, then? Regular germs?
Chief, they look like pollutants, uh, toxins, all f***ing horrible, and they're approaching the center!
The nucleus!
We must inform the control center immediately.
Toxins, oh, so it appears, are all black.
They seem to be heading for the central control post.
Pinpoint that, please, Chief Enzyme.
Quickly!
Ah, yes, I recognize them.
Smoke pollutants.
They must be got rid of at all costs.
oh dear on no account must they be allowed to reach the nucleus if they do we're in big trouble
hey hey that's my specialty maestro i belong to the antibody brigade and i'll dismantle the
dirty little monsters and two ticks but you're all alone yes i am but not for very long you'll
have to have a little bit of help those pollutants are tough run along then while we start instructing
the ribosome factory to make reinforcements for you stop the assembly lines initiate the synthesis
for making the detoxifying enzymes benzo attackers alert all competent
chromosomes immediately and hurry up about it this is an emergency six
chromosome 6 is needed immediately for production of detoxifying enzymes urgent
chromosome 6 please having a siesta why do they always pick on me I really wish
they'd leave me alone tta the cytochrome genes the detoxifying enzyme to vape them
would you please, immediately?
Inulatory enzymes, all of you over here, please.
Here, at the start of the antitoxin gene.
And at the end of the gene and its message.
Just after the end.
Now exit from the cell nucleus towards the ribosome factory.
No, no, no, idiot!
DNA is the information blueprint and must never ever leave the cell nucleus where it is protected.
Is that quite clear?
The copy, you must make a copy of that information, remember?
The original must stay where it is, always.
If not, the cell will lose precious information which will never be recovered.
I'm sick and tired of having to repeat this to you.
Taunt each of iron.
The antitoxin enzymes simply have to have iron right now.
But why do we need iron in proteins?
Because the iron gives them energy.
Go and order some from the spleen, the great iron reserves.
And quickly, we haven't got time to waste.
Right, Chief, sir, anything you say?
Hello, hello, am I speaking to the spleen factory?
We need some iron quickly, please.
Is that the spleen factory?
We need iron, it's urgent, it's badly needed for the fabrication.
This intestinal exportation center.
Check the number you have dialed.
This is the pyrobras.
Is that the spleen?
I have to have the spleen, the iron reserves.
This is the spleen.
What can we do for you, sir?
At last.
You've got to help us.
We need iron urgently.
You've simply got to help.
Hang on.
I need two million, uh, two million, three thousand iron atoms for the fabrication.
I know the mission of detoxifying enzymes.
We have noted your order, which will be processed immediately.
We thank you for your call.
Well, is the RNA messenger coming or what?
Here it is!
Here, Chief!
Good. You're going to have to cut the message while it's still moving.
And you too.
Glue the RNA messenger in place for the detoxifying enzymes.
The Gaze enzyme. I want you to stick that lot together immediately.
Come on, you! What's going on?
Oof!
Coming or not?
Mission accomplished.
With great success.
But you're detoxifying enzymes, my friends.
You're meant to protect the body against all kinds of toxins.
But I've the impression something's missing.
Think what on earth it can be.
Of course you need armor. What's missing is the iron.
We've placed an urgent order with the spleen, maestro.
The iron is en route.
At top speed, maestro.
Yes, it's a marshalling yard.
The spleen's over there.
They must be preparing a delivery of iron, no doubt.
The pedestrians to cross, they have the right of way.
But this is an urgent delivery.
No way we can stop now.
It took you so long, then.
Problems, you know.
But here's your iron, it's more.
It's not a minute too soon, I thought you'd never come.
We need to go on, then you can go first.
You know that, really wonderful. Have you quite finished?
Huh?
The cell is in great danger, and you have a mission to accomplish. Off you go.
The toxins have entered on the east side of the cell.
They're in close formation and moving in the direction of the nucleus. This is really serious.
Detox enzymes have been commanded to protect the nucleus at all costs, and to disarm the invaders.
Attack!
You're off!
The poison will never be destroyed.
If there was one more of these, where is it?
Just watch me!
Soames, there's danger of mutation, but I'll get him yet!
And?
Yes?
Maestro, something terrible has happened!
What's going on?
It's all the noise about damaged chromosomes.
It's chromosome 4!
There's a danger of mutation caused by a chemical pollutant.
That means that...
Well, a mutation is a change in the chromosomes,
and the changed cell may multiply.
And if that happens, there's a chance of cancer developing.
The bad cells attack the good ones and prevent them from working,
but there's no need to pass.
There's still a way out of all this.
But how, Meister?
There are several methods.
Our detoxifying enzymes can keep working,
while our bodyguards destroy the bad cells.
If they don't, a serious illness may develop.
The bad cells haven't started to reproduce.
We must call in our specialist enzymes to try and repair the DNA.
Activate the repair procedure at once.
It's a matter of extreme urgency.
Now we should see some action, I think.
Genetic material badly damaged.
That's awful.
My shoulder to help you out.
Thanks.
My nose. Watch out for my nose.
Does it.
All yours, XO.
You're helping us.
Why aren't you helping by keeping quiet when you know I'm the intellectual type and need time to think?
I'm the one who has to reassemble the DNA so it fits properly.
Pass me that long piece there.
And you, pass me the red.
A square piece?
Right, now take the whole lot.
Work of art, a masterpiece.
And now for the re-
Along this way.
Each other's hands and sit down, please.
And G, you take hold of A's hand, please.
Now keep dead still.
Hmm, and now you're all right again, aren't you?
For your help.
Repair to normal and good for duplication.
Repair, everything is okay now.
What's left is to put this back inside.
rest to recuperate.
It's all turned out well.
The human body has a remarkable capacity to cope with problems.
Let's see what's going on elsewhere.
There, all the toxins have been destroyed.
Very good.
Now we need the rubbish remover.
Demand to all rubbish trucks on the lysosome route.
Right, stop please and clean that mess up.
These are the lysosomes.
They're called the stomachs of the cell.
They digest rubbish in order to discharge it outside the cell.
Discharge from the cell.
Digestion completed.
Prepare for discharge from the cell.
Very good, I've got that discharge authorised.
Where's all this dirt come from?
All kinds of waste which the cell no longer wants, and which may be bad for it.
But don't worry about it, we're coming to the kidneys, and then we'll be quite clean.
Look there, we're approaching them already.
Oh, I'm stained all up, look at me, I'm not even presentable.
The kidneys, they're the centre for cleaning the blood, aren't they?
Am I right, Professor Globus?
Indeed they are, more than a litre of blood passes through each minute.
The fish is purified and thrown out.
Will we be cleaned?
Yes, you'll see. Watch out and hold on tight.
We'll meet up again at the exit.
Why, Holzer, is it dangerous?
Oh, no, don't worry about it.
We're entering a glomerulus, just a simple filtration system.
Not a spot of dirt left.
Did I tell you that nothing cleans like the kidneys?
They remove even the stubbornest stains.
Tell me, Professor, will reject dirt eventually go, then?
Um, well, you see, the body discharges it all.
So it goes into the bladder, and then what happens?
It just goes into the bladder.
Yes, but then?
Come on, Himo, you must know that.
I'm not quite sure.
Oh, you'll see.